[Music]
welcome to this episode of the click to
deploy series where we show you how easy
it is to deploy solutions from google
cloud marketplace
in this episode i'll show you how to set
up a mongodb deployment
through the google cloud marketplace
mongodb is a nosql document-oriented
database that stores json-like documents
with dynamic schemas when you are
building your projects you might be
interested in using mongodb as your
database
click to deploy makes it easy to quickly
spin up a mongodb instance
we'll start by searching for mongodb in
the gcp marketplace
[Music]
as you see we have a couple options for
mongodb from different vendors
you can deploy a container image of
mongodb or a virtual machine
for the purpose of this tutorial let's
choose the google click to deploy a
mongodb virtual machine
we are sent to this landing page which
shows some important information about
mongodb
like an overview of what mongodb is
details about the virtual machine and
its operating system
and most importantly the estimated
monthly cost of choosing the solution
let's click the launch button to start
this deployment
now we get to choose some important
specifications for our deployment
we'll start by naming our deployment for
this video
we will name it bongodb-101
we'll choose the zone for this tutorial
i'll keep the default zone
then you can decide on servers here for
this deployment which is how many
servers you want to deploy
i'll choose one next you can determine
your machine family and the machine type
this demo i'll use e2 high mim 4
which is a high memory machine type that
has 8 gigabytes of system memory per
vcpu
we'll keep the defaults for boot disk
type
you also have the option to select
arbiter tier
arbiter is a mongodb instance that is a
part of a replica set
but does not hold data and is instead
used to participate in elections
finally you can also decide on
additional specifications like cpu
platform
gpu network interface and firewalls
now we've completed the specification
we'll click the deploy button
great so now our mongodb vm is deployed
and now we see the deployment manager
the deployment manager allows you to
create
and manage cloud resources here we see
the deployed mongodb instance which
includes files that show vm instance
disk and firewall information
now we can test this mongodb instance by
running a couple of commands
[Music]
so there you have it a mongodb instance
created with a click of a button
if you enjoy this video please subscribe
and hit the like button below
if you'd like to deploy mongodb vm we
encourage you to check out the gcp
marketplace and deploy the solution on
your own thanks for watching
you